You ever feel like life is just slipping
away? You wake up, then check your phone
and reply to messages and scroll for a
bit and suddenly the day is over. Then
days turn into weeks and weeks turn into
months. But one question hits you every
night. Am I actually living or just
existing? And here's the truth most
people miss. Life doesn't get out of
control in one big moment. It slowly
drifts when you stop deciding. That's
why one habit changes everything. Design
your day before it begins and not a long
to-do list. Just decide what truly
matters before the world decides for
you. And do this daily. Then you stop
reacting. You start leading your life.
And if you're serious about 2026, then
watch my full video. I break down the
seven habits that can completely
transform your life in 2026. and take
action before you waste another